[Aplausos]
afinal o que torna o corpo real além da
sua existência física bom na minha
concepção que validar isso justamente o
meio a forma como a gente interage com o
mundo
mas e se mesmo assim você ainda
continuasse invisível bom em 2006 eu
sofri um acidente de carro e acabei me
tornando cadeirante e eu costumo dizer
que eu adquiri um combo eu ganhei uma
cadeira de rodas
eu ganhei um símbolo de deficiente e uma
série de títulos títulos quase sempre
acompanhados de frases como nossa você é
tão bonita na cadeira de rodas
nossa você é um exemplo de superação e
uma série de outros rótulos de
coitadismo de incapacidade
o fato é que em 2013 já decidi que eu
iria correr atrás dos meus próprios
títulos e para isso precisava entender o
que era uma limitação para mim então
escolhi fazer isso através de um
intercâmbio porque eu precisava estar
num local que me permitisse ter
acessibilidade para voltar a ter essa
interação comum
agora vocês podem imaginar o meu medo
depois de sete anos pela primeira vez eu
ia ficar sozinha e de quebra eu ainda
carregava um projeto
o blog guia do viajante cadeirante onde
eu me propus compartilhar todas as
descobertas naquela aventura
eu costumo dizer aventura porque pra mim
era um universo completamente novo pela
primeira vez eu conseguia
depois de sete anos andar em calçado que
não tinha problema de desnível não tinha
medo de cair pegava o ônibus pegava
metrô não tinha problema também é eu não
sabia ligar nos lugares previamente para
perguntar se tinha sensibilidade aliás o
começo até fazer isso mas de tanto me
deparar com o que não teria o claro a
gente tem
acabei desistindo e a questão do
estranhamento as pessoas
não me olhavam de maneira estranha na
rua porque era muito comum encontrar
muitos deficientes ao longo do dia
foi aí que eu fiz não era descoberta de
todas pra mim o problema não era está
sentada numa cadeira de rodas
o problema era viver no local deficiente
no local que não me permitia viver e ter
a independência que estava tendo lá as
pessoas precisam entender é que antes de
ser deficiente
nós somos pessoas diferentes como
qualquer pessoa
o fato de eu estar aqui falando sobre
esse assunto não me torna porta-voz dos
deficientes e nem quer dizer que todos
eles concordem comigo mas voltando
àquela questão da visibilidade do mundo
eu acredito que alguns conceitos alguns
fatores reforçam isso a falta de
acessibilidade
a falta de representatividade
vocês conseguem pensar agora nas imagens
sobre a deficiência que não sejam
veiculadas pela mídia com superação com
aquela reivindicação aquele pianinho no
fundo aquela imagem triste bom e o medo
o medo que as pessoas têm de falar sobre
esse assunto principalmente aqueles que
não são deficientes
o fato é que reunindo tudo isso eu
comecei a entender que se eu quisesse
fazer com que as pessoas me olharem de
uma maneira diferente eu deveria começar
a apresentar a minha realidade para elas
e eu acredito que o movimento tem que
ser o contrário eu acho que nós como
deficientes
devemos começar a apresentar as nossas
realidades porque a maioria das pessoas
não convivem com deficientes então não
tenho a menor idéia de como é que ele
universo uma grande maioria não todas
mas uma grande parte eu decidi fazer
isso então através da comunicação eo
veículo que eu utilizei foi a moda para
quem não sabe eu sou estilista e aí vem
a descoberta de mais um título
a de que deficientes não são vistos como
consumidores
é muito comum você hein
mas que não tenham acessibilidade e se
deparar com o proprietário que fala que
não adaptou aquele local porque
simplesmente não recebe deficientes
agora imagina transportar esse mesmo
pensamento para a moda que trabalha com
um padrão corporal com base naquilo que
é perfeito vocês podem imaginar a minha
dificuldade que essa mesma indústria não
entende a importância que ela exerce na
vida das pessoas com deficiência
eu vou citar dois exemplos a
independência no vestir
eu me lembro da primeira vez em que
depois de muito tempo isso não foram
dias eu conseguir me vestir pela
primeira vez sozinha e o pertencimento a
reaproximação com o meu corpo que aquilo
gerou foi muito gratificante ea
representatividade mais uma vez a moda
ela é um veículo de comunicação ea
representatividade ela quebra os
estereótipos dentro das minhas pesquisas
eu acabei fazendo descobertas também e
uma delas veio de uma deficiente visual
que começou a me contar como ela
consumir moda então ela falou michelle
eu não tenho é acesso à vitrine
eu num europeu nas roupas para poder
comprar uma roupa então eu nunca sempre
está ali
quando eu vou a uma loja de
departamentos
elas são gigantescas e não sei nem por
onde começar e aí chega um vendedor que
tá totalmente atrapalhado ele não é
muito comum receber um deficiente visual
e não sabe por onde começar e ele acabou
me atrapalhando mais do que ajudando
quando eu perguntei para ela a questão
das informações ela falou
imagina não tem informação de moda
porque a maioria dos sites não tem áudio
descrição as revistas não trabalham com
isso tão ou seja o nome a 0
agora o que como é que uma indústria que
teoricamente deveria atender a todos os
corpos porque afinal todo mundo veste
acaba impondo limitações e excluindo
copo sem ao menos entender
as necessidades desses corpos foi com
base nisso então que o projeto hashtag
meu corpo é real nasceu a idéia foi da
voz ativa aos consumidores através de
ações ea nossa primeira ação foi através
do mini documentário onde a gente eu
posso por esses consumidores
eles colocaram a forma como eles se
relacionavam com a moda
o que eles gostavam o que precisava ser
melhorado tudo isso num ambiente lúdico
é esse documentário que se passa nos
bastidores de um ensaio fotográfico é
onde eu procurei trabalhar essa estética
conceitual que é tão trabalhada pela
moda como uma forma justamente de
comprovar que esses corpos merecem sim
ser trabalhados pela moda e não sobre
aqueles velhos clichês que a mídia
costuma veicular
quando a gente fala nas barreiras que o
desconhecido alimenta
eu me lembro perfeitamente do primeiro
dia em que eu fui pra começar minha
pós-graduação em comunicação e cultura
de moda e me deparei com uma classe de
olhares curiosos
afinal não era tão comum encontrar um
estilista cadeirante a minha iniciativa
então foi levar uma cadeira de rodas em
segundo na segunda semana de aula e
convidar é esses estudantes a
experienciar em meu universo então ele
vem essas pessoas para banheiro sem
adaptação pras ruas pra locais públicos
com a única condição de que elas agissem
exatamente como um cadeirante então se
houvesse barreiras físicas elas não
poderiam levantar da cadeira terem pedir
ajuda e principal olhar a maneira como
as pessoas se relacionavam com elas
toda essa experiência acabou fazendo
para pensar que se eu quisesse um dia
colocar esses corpos na moda deveria
estreitar algumas relações entre o
consumidor com deficiência amido as
marcas e os profissionais do futuro que
são os estudantes
foi então que nasceu fechando inclusivo
o faixa de inclusive um evento que a
gente realize em hospitais de
reabilitação e esses os pais geralmente
recebem pessoas que nasceram deficientes
se tornaram deficientes ao longo da vida
então nós recrutamos estudantes do setor
de moda para mapear em através de
entrevistas às reais necessidades desses
pacientes com o intuito de aproximar
justamente essas estudantes estudantes
dos pacientes
no final desse evento a gente distribui
kits que recebem o apoio das empresas
então a gente acaba fechando esse ciclo
eu sei que o faz um bem inclusive ele
deu tão certo que a gente está na
terceira edição que vai acontecer agora
no dia 7 de dezembro
o que me emociona muito porque eu
entendo que tudo aquilo que eu aprendi
naquele intercâmbio hoje é realizado de
maneira inversa
hoje eu consigo desmistificar o universo
de quase 24% da população brasileira que
têm alguma deficiência para esses
estudantes
então o que eu trago para vocês hoje é
que você se permitam ser corpos reais
que vocês entendam que o diferente não é
algo negativo porque ninguém é igual a
ninguém que o meu corpo é real
[Aplausos]